[Musik]
mona vetsch freitag 10
es ist auch besonders rätselhaft
ah
jetzt klarer ankunft 2 flughafen zürich
glaube ist noch
ihren eigenen gerne überraschen
der flughafen ist schnell gefunden und
jetzt die
momentan trug ich muss irgendwie oder
abholer ankunft 2 ist das irgendwie auch
40 vom flughafen kommt das sind
ereignete kamen dieses jahr bewegen die
beträge ich sage jetzt moderieren mordes
oder remis wenigstens vier personen
warum willst du was auf dem
schulhof nicht strahlend mona jeden aber
fehlerhaft aber lösen von rätseln wohin
ich glaube sie waren durch die gleiche
gruppe will hier ich bin aus korea
reise mit witz und jetzt war die gruppe
ja ich bin der leiter von der
reisegruppe
[Musik]
also ich mit monat
erhöht was ist das für ein name
so heiß war
und mit alles zum hiking
auslaufen
ist die schlimmste steht
die längste waren blickt sie bestimmt
und wenn nicht kannst du mich träge
[Musik]
da dies nicht mitglieder von mister
leasing gruppe ii
17 die insgesamt
für die nächsten drei monate unterwegs
in eine asiatische touristen gruppe gut
vorbereitet abrufbares quast das ist saf
heimatland monat mittendrin
bevor ich recht weiß wie mir geschah
werden oder ihnen gar ist berner
oberland verfrachtet und ich mir oft
angesprochen
die frau ist extra für mich doch zum
übersetzer
das freut mich sehr wir müssen auf ich
einsteigen
[Musik]
der reiseleiter misteli macht der
bordunterhaltung und dann stellt sich
jeder für unsere reisegruppe selber vor
dank der human versteht nur bahnhof
spezialisiert sozusagen
[Musik]
da sind mini reisegefährte für die
nächsten tag sie sind alle tot bergen
jetlag ist für sie der firma bix und so
16 morgen
[Musik]
ankunft in grindelwald
den bezug vom hotel findet er erst die
stadt
[Musik]
tatsächlich premiere
am nächsten morgen zeigt das berner
oberland von seiner schönsten seite
zum besser kontakt zu der koreaner zu
finden hilft mir tun die sibe school of
deutschland studieren und werde mir die
daheimgeblieben tun an stellt man ein
koreaner vor wo autotrader com
studiums deutschland
nur mehr stunde richtige dann sehen sie
jetzt müde
und auf dem jungfraujoch waren sie schon
weil ich war noch nie da
[Musik]
der mystery verteilt bauen die ätherisch
im rucksack für sie nie lügt mit die
danach
letzten acht eines problems das problem
ja ich habe beschlossen
ich habe schlüssel im zimmer vergessen
und sich schlafen
der zweit bäcker oder wo heinz ich
schlafe
rufen boote
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auf der fahrt richtung klinik stellt man
tue nahm die einzige frage von boni mal
reisen
sie sind beide zum ersten mal in der
schweiz und sie sind jegliche
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das ist der ökonom das ist der heikelste
gletscher das und da ist ja das ist eine
gute frage
hier ist ein
mensch mensch
und das ist wieder fraglich ja da gehen
wir hin
[Musik]
ruft weiter fortsetzt einigem ihm auch
teil unserer reisegruppe kilo entpuppt
sich als popstar aus taiwan die schweiz
für ihren neuesten videoclip wir
handyfilme mitteilt sie alles mit ihrer
fans die
jungfrau heisterberg
denn zeigt mir nur noch ein musik clips
auf youtube
er ist acht millionen dollar geworden
und der neue clip bayern roland
schweizer sind becker musik videos und
spiele fehlen so berühmt vor der nur 100
besucher pro jahr auf dem jungfraujoch
sind zwei drittel und asien am meisten
mit koreaner
[Musik]
dem lift wird richtig
ein erster höhepunkt für mini koreaner
die 12 auf in bergen aber die sind nicht
einmal 2000 meter höhe
[Musik]
im obligaten gibt sofort die lehrer
nicht dass mit korea nicht schießt seit
sondern kind
[Musik]
minus vier grad
mini freundin jule aus dem zug an item
trubel übrigens nähe gefunden dafür als
bei andré taiwanese
[Applaus]
gebückt
[Musik]
sport abwärts ist reisegruppe stieg die
station eigergletscher
wir sind ja nicht zum vergnügen sondern
andere mir frau die voll
auskostet sehen durch die einzige uni
städtischen regionen nationalsport jede
macht
ich darf korea
jedes hoch gelangt und die berge
also wenn ich südkorea speedweek asien
[Musik]
vor allem wanderer dank der koreaner
stoße die neue dimensionen vor vom
schweizer nationalsport
[Applaus]
die zweistündige wanderung verfügt ist
nun eines warmlaufen für die große tour
von morgen wo sie bestimmt gut
[Musik]
die messe stellen 470 luther juristen
nach
entpuppt sich sogar als ehemaliger
oberster richter von korea
grad über seine vergangenheit und über
geschichte von schweden aus
vom föderalismus direkt zum
schweigsamen das speziell die recker
wehr mit brot verliebt dennis
tornieporth
waren sie nah da muss endlich etwas
passiert signal
für mich geht sauer kulinarische
überraschung
gemüse
achtung und dem sie selbst herstellen
nein es ist wie das ist gut
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
er baute berner oberland wenn ihr wisst
los police evans politik und
adelboden liegt
die
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oberhand
hier platzierte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für proben bestanden
wird gar zu groß
sie bestand wanderer buchte ordentlich
proviant leidet grindelwald sind zwar
stellt auf touristen aber kim chi findet
dafür anders
route vom 4 der chemiker platte wo macht
gilt dass eine von der schönsten
wanderwegen in der schweiz
zweiter ist noch unsicher
der mystery gott wir im office und gitta
takt an
[Musik]
ja ja
mit diesem grunde sitze die beiden
freunde
sie verzeichnet der human dass ihnen die
erste schweizerin grünburg farbe lila
bis korea ganz anders in der frühe
halbmillionenstadt busan
handy eigentlich familie
wir tun schon
jungs
dass sie zu jung
sie hat als student die heirat ist oder
sie
dazu und ein beitritt noch lesen
sie wo sie zum überholen angesetzt so
viele vorlagen
[Gelächter]
fürchterlich vor mir und iss nicht nur
bei sturm koreanerinnen
[Musik]
große familie pflicht für miss fortune
hätte also eher für
[Gelächter]
die
koreaner die schönste frau therese
weniger und der barmer mono
weder geht es mit temperaturen um fünf
grad ist das auch nötig
im stöckli spiel gibt stars steigern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wandere zähne mit dem ehemaligen
oberste richter von korea in hermine und
ganz ehrlich zu sein die am anfang
haben wir gedacht ja eine asiatische
reisegruppe ja ja wenn die sagen wir
wandern dann laufen sie mit mit
turnschuhen laufen sie vielleicht einen
kilometer ja und das ist wandern fahren
habe ich gedacht hat aber auch die
alpine elite von korea oder kommt in
dieser gruppe zusammen
gerade mein zweiter verdi langsam besser
wird es noch schlechter
in der schweiz wir haben da auch schnee
im juli
ein optimist
zum zmittag gott übte auf dem schulhof
und pausen geplant ich freue mich
aber mal sperrte koreanische widerruf
genau geschluckt und sie zum richtig
viel mehr annika es geht nur als billige
handy aufnahme und wieder
ganz foto stifter mystery am tempo
machen
als letzte mini beide frauen mussten
grund meines wechsels
schönste panorama vom berner oberland
das kann nur sagen
mir ist die ziel sein suri jahre vor dem
man sich gerne zudem welt durch also ich
glaube crunchy zu wir wieder im
beiträgen in gewandelter
forderte 11 alles resol ihr comeback
kaliabsatz
schweiz wo die vitale drehen das jahr
der koreaner die csu
beharrt man jetzt hält die für die 15
kilometer
240 nicht weit vorne irgendwo dem ist
also warum die schweizer stirken einmal
gehörig luft schwächer erwartete
deutsche airshow
ab durch die mitte forschung zu
schädigen platte
[Musik]
irgendwann anschluss wieder gefunden und
zwar klare darf
[Musik]
tropez moral ist intakt und jetzt geht
sogar noch trinkpause fünf
lange pause keine die nordkorea
könnte auf wenige platte
die pforte zu kaufen ist
unbedingt
langsam sage ich dass ihr die
bayerischen nie zu sehen
die schweizer sind ja bekannt dafür
immer glücklich aber ihr koreaner sind
noch möglich
wir sind sogar so pünktlich dass remus
frühjahr da sehen das typisch für so
schnell machen
[Musik]
der mystery ich übrigens sogar endlich
rog sie uns schlechte wetter
zuständige antriebe wie es ihm und
wetter gesegnet
[Musik]
sie dachten ich
langsam sehe ich aus wie jemand der nur
langsam läuft ja ja
jetzt ist wieder ausgeglichen weil ich
dachte er auch das koreaner nicht
schnell war ich da auch koreaner können
nur spazieren
jetzt wer wird ihn kriegt
[Gelächter]
und dennoch sie bestand sie immer
forscht am ziel
wir sehen glaubt alle froh
jetzt ich bin kaputt geworden
war wirklich wirklich
das also sie sind auch ein am ende jetzt
ja ja
mir macht
macht ja
kraft kraft
jetzt kuriere stieg dazu mehrere
koreanische reisegruppe
[Musik]
mit dem letzten band
zum glück auswärts noch mal vier stunden
[Musik]
die
juve und dem global ziemlich cool
[Musik]
dieses lied stets markets grindelwald
und wie wie geht es nach der langen
wanderung ist
das gut
so wir
heute müssen wir uns verabschieden also
wo auf dem bahnsteig sie gehen
ich gehe nach hause
wir müssen schon wieder liest schon
wieder vorne dankeschön
herzlich wird mehr oder regisseur mark
waters bekommt den sinn was tun nahm
seit koreaner geld auf die italiener für
südostasien
sie sagt oft lustig und emotional
in dieser gruppe ich habe sehr lange
gebraucht die sich die einzelnen
menschen voneinander unterscheiden
konnten es gibt ja schon dieses klischee
dass wir so sehr sagen also sie sehen
alle ein bisschen gleich aus die asiaten
ich höre diese bemerkung als ehrten
sehen alle gleich aus sie leidet dichter
in die vision kündigt das und deswegen
na ja manchmal sage ich dann eher das
geht auch umgekehrt
aber die leute wollen dass ich glaube
wir
können
ja das geht da für uns die asiaten haben
eben auch genauso probleme
sehr verschieden aussehen
nicht aus
also ich habe am anfang
meine
nase ist schon groß
interlaken ist der not zum souvenir
posten das gehört zu einer schweiz der
asiate einfach dazu ich schließe mich da
beide frauen zu wort und soja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so absurd es nicola für ihre sammlung zu
acht schlug die heile welt
das so klein die mitte wie sehr eine
größere
also wieder zum nächsten job aber da
gibt's kein großes problem also nimmt
zum gehalt besonderes mitbringsel und
wie ein drehtag wunder
dass alles extra denn so 8 für für
interlaken das ist schon was ganz
bewusst ja überhaupt sehr chinesisch
sprechen die gäste ja indische politik
relativ lange nicht er habe ich mache
was ich denn das am meisten verkaufte
das der streng im moment ist dadurch
wieder kühler
luft luft von jung soo jung und draußen
ja
das aufgesogen mit
320 frankreich austin texas
bis zum treffpunkt am bahnhof mache ich
mich nur noch ein abschiedsgeschenk für
koreanische
gefunden
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
so collection
wenn du denkst ich lehne schmid mit mehr
große herz
ali andress mit dem kleine goldbarren
ist
ein großes
[Gelächter]
geschenk
also immer dann ganz herzlichen dank
dankeschön im moment ist die glaubte ich
denke
seit für korea ganz herzlichen dank
sind sie für mich einfach ein gruppen
asiatic sie und jetzt will die termin
sommer und alle anderen am liebsten im
ziel
das ist so schnell gar von fremd zu
freund
[Musik]
doch doch es gilt erstens ein dick
der grösste schweizer
nationalrat machen
aber nicht mit
drin und meine scham limit das geht es
nächste woche monat mittendrin
[Musik]